[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصفه في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ينهي جولته في الشرق الاوسط عقب محادثات
مع الرئيس محمود عباس اما هذه الصور
فتاتينا من ورسو حيث قال نائب وزير الدفاع
البولندي ان بلاده لا تجري محادثات لارسال
مقاتلات من طراز اف 16 الى اوكرانيا وذلك
بعد يوم من استبعاد الولايات المتحده
تسليما مقاتلات مماثله
وهذه الصور من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
التي شهدت اليوم مظاهرات شارك فيها مئات
الاف الاشخاص احتجاجا على تعديل نظام
التقاعد وتقدم المسيره رؤساء النقابات
الرئيسيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في ختام جوله الشرق اوسطيه بلنكن يشددوا
على ضروره وقف العنف والتصعيد بشكل فوري
ويؤكد تمسك واشنطن بتطبيق حل الدولتين على
المدى البعيد عباس يحمل اسرائيل كامل
المسؤوليه عن التوتر ويؤكد رفض
الفلسطينيين لاستمرار الاحتلال للابد
تمديد حاله الطوارئ في تونس لغايه نهايه
العام الجاري الرئيس التونسي يدعو القوات
المسلحه والقضاه للتصدي لمن وصفهم
بالمتامرين على الدوله ورئيس جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه يتهم سعيد بتوظيف القضاء
العسكري للانتقام من خصومه
قمه اوكرانيه اوروبيه في اكياز الجمعه
المقبل
والهدف دعم كياب في الحرب وتسريع مسار
انضمامها للاتحاد الاوروبي بعيدا يؤكد انه
سيبحث مع زلينسكي الاسلحه المطلوبه
بعد رفضه توفير مقاتلات اف 16
تايم بولندا ودول البلطيق بتصعيد المواجهه
مع روسيا وتحذرها من التداعيات
في جوله متزامنه للامين العام للنيتو
ووزير الدفاع الامريكي في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ ستوطن بورد يؤكد من
اليابان ان التعاون الروسيه الصيني او وجد
اخطر بيئه امنيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
يبحث في سول استراتيجيات الرضع ضد كوريا
الشماليه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اسباب احجام قرابه 90% من
الناخبين التونسيين عن المشاركه في الجوله
الثانيه للانتخابات البرلمانيه وتبرير
الرئيس قيس سعيد هذا الامر بالقول ان
تونسيين لم يعودوا يثقون في البرلمان
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما اسباب عزوف الناخبين
التونسيين عن المشاركه في الاقتراع
النيابيه وجاءت الاجابه على نحو التالي
نحو 58% اعتبروا ان السبب هو عدم ثقه
الناخبين في البرلمان بينما حاله نحو 15%
السبب الى الازمه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
وفي راي السابعه 27% فان مسار الخامسه
والعشرين مليون الذي اطلقه الرئيس سعيد هو
السبب وراء تدني نسبه مشاركه في
الانتخابات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
من العاصمه باريس الى مارسيليا جنوبا ونوط
غربا ومدن اخرى اكثر من مليون متظاهر
يحتشدون في انحاء فرنسا احتجاجا على
مشروعا لتعديل نظام التقاعد واضرابات
تتسبب في تعطيل امدادات الطاقه وحركه
النقل والمدارس
[موسيقى]
شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلنكن
على ضروره اتخاذ الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين اجراءات فوريه لخفض العنف
ومنع المزيد من التصيد
مباحثاته مع الرئيس الفلسطيني تمسك واشنطن
بحل الدولتين وضروره عدم اتخاذ خطوات قد
تقود تحقيقه من جانب حمل محمود عباس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل المسؤوليه عن
التصعيد والتوتر الذي تشهده الاراضي
الفلسطينيه مشدد على ان الفلسطينيين لا
يقبلون استمرار الاحتلال للابد
زياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله واسرائيل جاءت في
توقيت استثنائيا ودقيقه لكن نتائجها لم
ترقى على ما يبدو الى مستوى التحديات
والاوضاع الخطيره بين الجانبين حيث قال
انتون بلنكن خلال مؤتمر صحفي في ختام
زيارته انه طلب من الجانبين اتخاذ خطوات
لمنع حدوث اي تصعيده وابتعاد عن الخطوات
الاحاديه الجانب التي من شانها تقود حل
الدولتين
ومازلنا نعرض الاجراءات احاديه الجانب من
كلا الجانبين التي تغذي التوتر وتخود الى
بيئه اكثر خطوره وتجعل احتمال المضي قدما
باتجاه حل الدولتين اكثر صعوبه
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس الذي حمل
بدوره اسرائيل مسؤوليه التصعيد بقتل
الفلسطينيين وشجب خطه توسيع الاستيطان على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه في غياب الضغوط
الدوليه عليها
يعني تتحمل مسؤوليته الحكومه الاسرائيليه
في سبب ممارساتها التي تقود حل الدولتين
وتخالف الاتفاقات الواقعه
وبسبب عدم بذل الجهود الزوج الدوليه
لتفتيك الاحتلال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الذي تجنب التطرق الى الشان الفلسطيني
وركز على اتفاقات ابرهام في اشاره الى
اتفاقيات التطبيع بين اسرائيل ودول
المنطقه وتفاؤله اساءها رغم تاكيد واشنطن
بانها ليست بديلا عن حل الدولتين مع
الفلسطينيين رغم كونها حاجه توجد لدى
الاداره الامريكيه استراتيجيه واضحه
للتوسل الى تهدئه التي تنشدها بوجود حكومه
اسرائيليه لا حدود لتطرفها ولا يجد بعض
وزرائها عشان في التفاخر بالتركيب
الفلسطينيه
الجزيره القدس الغربيه
ينضم الينا من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي ومعنى من واشنطن ريتشرد جودسين
المبعوث الخاص السابق للرئيس بل كلينتون
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط مرحبا بكم او سنبدا
معك همم سيد ريتشارد دودسين خفض التوتر
معارضه الاجراءات الاحاديه الجانب تجديد
الدعم لحل الدولتين هي المواقف التي عبر
عنها وزير الخارجيه بلانكن ولكن كيف تعتزم
الاداره الامريكيه تحقيق تقدم في هذا
الشان بما يتجاوز فقط الكلام
موعد الصلاه
[موسيقى]
الان ولكن هو يشمل بذلك توسع
وسلطنات واي
حديثا
يتماشياني مع قرار اتخذته الاداره وعكس
ترامب يظهر رئيس الامريكي ان هذا امر غير
مقبول اعتقد ان ما يهم هو ما يحصل خلف
الكواليس ولكن ما يقال بكل صراحه وعلى من
يبدو ايجابيا
تجاهي العملي على همم حقيقي تقدم معين
دكتور سليم بريك اذا ما يقال يبدو ايجابيا
باتجاه تحقيق تقدم ولا يجب الاستخفاف بهذه
المواقف الامريكيه ما رايك
مساء الخير ارسل لك والمشاهدين والضيفك
الكريم
هو عمليا اكامول جرعه من الاكامول لا اكثر
اولا هو يتحدث عن دوله فلسطينيه او حل
دولهتين في المدى البعيد ولكن نحن الان 29
عاما من اتفاقيات اوسلوه التي وقعت في
سنبر 1993 وحل الدول ثانيه يبتعد القضيه
الثانيه التي يجب ان تكون واضحه للجميع
بان التلك الامريكي والتحيز الامريكي
لجانب الاسرائيلي هو الذي ولد هذه الحكومه
المتطرفه في في القدس او الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي ترفض نهائيا حول
الدولتين حكومه تتنياهم مبنيه على
الصهيونيه الدينيه التي ترفض بشكل نهائي
وعمليا تريد ان تضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
نعم ما اتى به لين كان عمليا هو ثلاث صفات
لبنانيه من نتنياهو انا لا استغفر في هذا
الموضوع باعتقادي انه وضح للجانب
الاسرائيلي لان كل العمليات الاستيطان
والتوسع وضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه غير وارد
باعتقاد هذا امر جيد ولكن في طبيعه الحال
هذا غير كافي وبعيد جدا عن ان يكون في
مستوى التوقعات الفلسطينيه من دوله عظمى و
احدى واهم راعي للمفاوضات الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه
السلطات الاسرائيليه على التجاوب مع هذا
لينكن بغياب اي ضغط امريكي على الطرف
الاسرائيلي
انا ال- لم اسمع انه لم يكن هناك اي ضغط
على اسرائيل في الحقيقه الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل تتعاملني مع بعضهما حول جوانب
مختلفه احدها موضوع ايران
اخر من العلاقات ايضا لدينا الجانب
المتعلق باوكرانيا حيث هناك طيارات ايران
يا موسى
[موسيقى]
الكبير امام اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
لتتعاونها وتتحول كل منهما اقناع الدوله
الاخرى بموقعها نعرف ان هناك الكثيره
مخصصه لاسرائيل ولكن لا يجيبوا الكثير عن
الاهتمام لما لما
هنا الضغط بهذه المساعدات الى اسرائيل
ولاسيه مع المساعدات العسكريه كيف لهذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان تستجيب لعدم توسيع
الاستيطان وللعوده الى الانخراط في موضوع
حل الدولتين
حاليا
في اسرائيل او في الاراده الفلسطينيه
مباشره
[موسيقى]
عندما يتم الحديث عن خطوط امريكيه لن يمكن
للطرف الاسرائيلي ان يتخطاها
لا نعتقد انه طرف الاسرائيلي يخطط للمزيد
من المستوطنات ويتحدثون عن هذا بشكل علني
وضم مناطق من منطقه
اخرى اضافيه تخطط لهذه الحكومه وعلى
اساسها اقيمت هذه الحكومه باعتقادي انه
جدول اعمال
مع الاسرائيليين هدف لامرين الامر الاول
التواصل لتهدئه معينه لكي يستطيع التوسع
في اتفاقات اثرها ضم العربيه السعوديه
لهذه الاتفاقات وكي لا تقوم السلطه
الفلسطينيه
بمعارضه هذا التوجه الموضوع الثاني والذي
هو شديد الاهميه هو التنسيق الاسرائيلي
الامريكي بالنسبه لايران وايضا بالنسبه
الى اوكرانيا وتزويد ايران من مسيرات وهذه
الامور وفي الدرجه الثالثه والاخيره
الموضوع الفلسطيني وكل ما هو مطلوب من
عباس عمليا هو الانتظار والانتظار
والانتظار هذه هي السياسه الامريكيه طالما
ان الامريكان ليسوا محايدين ويدعمون
اسرائيل بشكل مطلق اسرائيل ستستمر في هذه
همم التصرفات ونحن نرى هذا الامر بتركيبه
الحكومه وبتركيبه الائتلاف الاخير شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور سليم بريك استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والخبير في شان الاسرائيلي ضيفنا
من الناصره وشكرا للسيد ريتشارد جوتن
المبعوث الخاص للسابق للرئيس بالكلينسن
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط من واشنطن
وقد شهد حي جبل المكبر في القدس مواجهه
بين القوات الاسرائيليه وفلسطينيين
وتزاملت المواجهات مع تنفيذ سكان الحي
اضرابا شاملا احتجاجا عمل على عمليات
الهدم الانتقاميه التي اقرها المجلس
الامني والمصغر في اسرائيل واغلق الاهالي
بعض مداخل الحي بالاطارات المطاطيه
المشتعله والحلويات والحجاره في محاوله
لمنع قوات الاحتلال من اقتحامه
[موسيقى]
يشتغل غضب الفلسطينيين بالقدس المحتله
هكذا بدات مداخل حي جبل المكبر في ساعات
الصباح الاولى
وكانها ساحه معركه حيث عمل الاضراب الشامل
مناحي الحياه كافه
الاهالي هنا على هدم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لمنزل عائله مطر
لاي عمليات هدم اخرى في مقبل
يعني اذا بدنا نرخص ولا بدنا نعمل اي شيء
500 واحد طلعه لواحد
لم يخلو الامر من مواجهات بين الفلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال فقد سد الشبان مداخل الحي
بكل ما طالت ايديهم ورشقوا دوريات
الاحتلال بالحجاره ورد الجنود عليهم
بقنابل الغاز المدمع والرصاص المطاطي بحسب
مصادر الطبيه وقعت المواجهات نحو 20
اصابتا في صفوف سكان
الحيض التي تقودها حكومه الاحتلال
المتطرفات والافرات بالقتل واعطاء الضوء
الاخضر الجيش الاحتلال وشرطته بقتل اي
فلسطين يتحرك هذا يعزز المطلب الفلسطيني
بضروره ان يكون هناك حمايه دوليه
وما زالت عائله مطر تلملموا جراحها بعد
هدم الاحتلال منزلها فقط كان ذلك ترجمه
سريعه لقرارات المجلس الوزاري المصغر في
اسرائيل الذي اطلق يد الات الهدم للنيل من
المقدسيين بعد عمليتين مسلحتين هزت اركان
حكومه اليمن
[موسيقى]
وحدات النخبه لاسناد قوه الشرطه ودعم
نشاطها في حفظ الوضع الامني
يسدد الاحتلال من قبضه على القدس ويحاصر
احيائها الفلسطينيه بتدابير امنيه لا يبدو
انها ستنتهي قريبا وهو ما يمكن بابا
مواربا على مزيد من الاحتجاجات والمواجهات
التي بدات تتخذ شكلا او ساعه واعم
الجزيره من حي جبل المكبر القدس المحتله
اسرائيليه
زعتر العسكري جنوب نابلس وفقا لموقعه ولا
الاخباري العربي وقال الناطق العسكري باسم
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان قوته بدات
تحقق في ملابسات العمليه واغلقت قوت
الاحتلال عده شوارع في المنطقه كما نصبت
حواجز عسكريه ضمن عمليات تمشيطا واسعه
بحثا عن المشتبه بتنفيذه العملي
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث مددت السلطات التونسيه حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد الى نهايه العام الجاري
وفق ما جاء في مرسوم صدره في الجريده
الرسميه ودابت السلطات التونسيه على تمديد
حاله الطوارئ لمدد تتراوح بين شهر وثلاثه
اشهر منذ اعلنتها لاول مره عام 2012 عقب
قيام الثوره لكن تعد هذا المره الاولى
التي تمدد فيها الطوارئ لعام كامل
دعا الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد القوات
المسلحه والامنيه والقضاه للتصدي لمن
اعتبرهم متامرين على الدوله وقال سعيد
خلال زيارته لسكنه الحرس الوطني بالعاصمه
التونسيه انه لا يمكن بقاء من سماهم اعداء
الوطن خارج نطاق المساءله
عليكم
المسلحه الامنيه
وقواتنا المسلحه العسكريه التي قامت بدور
تاريخيا ايضا في تامين الانتخابات عليكم
وعلى القضاه الشرفاء
ان يقوم بدورهم
كامله
حتى
يتم التصدي
لمن تعامروا على الدوله
بسنوات الماضيه
وما سالوا الى حد هذه الساعه
يتامرون على الدوله
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان الداعين
لقطع الطرق في البلاد لن يبقوا خارج
المساءله مضيفا الحق نقبي مضمون بموجب
الدستور لكن مشدد على انه لا يمكن ان
يتحول هذا الحق لتحقيق مارب سياسيه
اليوم التهديد بقطع الطريق السياره
لا يمكنه ان يبقوا خارجه دائره المسائله
الحق النقابي مضمون
بده السور
ولكن
الحق النقابي لا يمكن ان يتحول الى غطاء
لمقارب السياسيه لم تعد تخفى على احد
في مقابل ذلك اتهم رئيس جبهه الخلاص
الوطني في تونس احمد نجيب الشابي الرئيس
سعيد بتوظيف القضاء العسكري للانتقام من
خصومه واصدار احكام كلها تتعلق بتدوينات
او تصريحات اعلاميه واعتبر الشاب في
مداخلته خلال ندوه سياسيه ان المحاكمات
العسكريه مضره بسمعه البلاد وبحياد الجيش
واكد الشاب ان الحقبه التي يصفها الرئيس
قيس سعيد بالعشريه السوداء كانت عشريه
الحريات والمؤسسات والفصل بين السلطات حسب
تعبير
هذا توظيف للمؤسسه العسكريه في الحياه
السياسيه
وان هذا مضر بالبلاد
ومضر بحياد الجيش
وبسمعته العاليه التي تقوم اولا واساسا
على الحياد في الحياه السياسيه لقد ساءنا
ونقولها بملئه بملا كلامنا
ساءنا ان نرى دبابه للجيش الوطني التونسي
تتجه صبيحه 25 جوليا لتغلق باب البرلمان
وتمنع نواب الشعب المنتخبين انتخابا حرا
من من وصلته وظائفهم التي اقسم على ان
يؤدوها احسن اداء
دعا فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده الى اجراء حوار مفتوح
وشاملا بين جميع الاطراف المعنيه في تونس
لتجاوز المشاكل التي شهدتها البلاد جاء
ذلك ردا على سؤال لمراسل الجزيره بشان
اضعف الاقبال على التصويت في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات البرلمانيه
في تونس في جهودهم لايجاد حلل المشكلات
التي حدثت في الاشهر الاخيره هناك ما نود
ان نراه هو حوار مفتوح وشامل بين جميع
اصحاب المصلحه في هذا الصدد
اس ان اوه ينضم الينا من تونس بالحسن
اليحيوي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي والسيد
سمير ديلو المحامي وعضو اللجنه التنفيذيه
لجبهه الخلاص الوطني مرحبا بكم حسن ما
الرساله من وراء حديث الرئيس قيس سعيد
دعوته القوات المسلحه والقضاه القيام
بدورهم بالتصدي لمن يتامرون على الدوله
كما فهمتها
الرئيس
بعد الارقام التي سجلتها الانتخابات
التشريعيه في دورتها الثانيه
واحد من اهم الملفات التي من اجلها وتقى
تونسيون يتعلق المحاسبه
ومحاسبه الفاسيين ومحاسبات
الرئيس سعيد هي التي جعلت الكثير من مكان
يدعمونه في مسار الخامس والعشرين من
اشبيليه من حاله الانظار ويبدو انه الان
بصدد الذكيه انه يتابع وانه مصر على ان
تكون سياق المحاسبه ان يذهب في سياق
قانونيه وهو عاده الى حادث شهاده الناس
مؤخرا تتعلق بحديث الجرجس وغرق عدد من
الشبان في محاوله لمخادره الحدود
طيب هي الشرعيه
والتي تزامدت او الاضطرابات التي تزامت مع
القمهفونيه واتحدث عن هذا الموضوع ببعض
التفصيل بعد ان وعد انذاك بانه سوف يفتح
هذا الموضوع بالنهايه موضوع المحاسبه الذي
يهم التونسيين والذي يطالبوا بالتونسيون
يعيد الرئيس قيس سعيد رفعه من شديد
ومحاسبه الفاسدين ومن اجرمه
ليس هناك ما يمنع السيد السعيد اول مؤسسات
الدوله من القيام بذلك
بدون وجه الى العنوان الخطا الحديث عن
المسارات القضائيه لا يكون في ثكنه امنيه
ثم هذا التقسيم بين قضاء الخلفاء واخرين
غير الشرفاء والحديث بنبره توحي بانه يقصد
معارضيه السيد رئيس اضاعه فرصه يعترف بفشل
مساره لقائه برئيسه الحكومه بالامس كان
تحت شعار
المكابره ولقائه اليوم بقيادات الامنيه
كانت تحت شعار الهروب الى الامام
ماذا عن حديثه عن ان الحق به لا يمكن ان
يتحول الى غطاء لمئارب سياسيه لم تعد تخفى
على احد الى ما يحيل هذا الكلام في
المرحله المقبله
لا ما وصل حقيقه من المعلوم ايضا النشاط
بعض النقابات امنيه وغير امنيه
كبير لدى تونسيين وبعض هذه النشاطات تمثل
عائقا امام يعني بعض المؤسسات في بعض
المؤسسات الخاصه في ما يتعلق بقصه الملف
الازرق
اين يقع اعتماد الرئيس الاكبر على انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه من الحاله الاقتصاديه
والحاله الماليه
وحاله انتاج الفوسفات في العشريه الاخيره
تدهورت الى ماذا
الى العديد من المقالب النقابيه الى
ارتفاع
يعني عدد العمل
بمناطق انتاج الفوسفات خاصه
هذه الاضرابات التي تعطل الانتاج
ما يتعلق اساسا وقبل كل شيء الى جانب بعض
القطاعات الاخرى التي قامت في الفتره
الاخيره بالاضرابات العشوائيه والمطالب
الاجتماعيه مع اهتراء الماليه العموميه
وعدم قدره الماليه العموميه على الايفاء
بالعديد من الالتزامات خاصه تلك الاتفاقات
التي حدثت مع الاتحاد العام للشغل فيما
يتعلق بزيادات
سيد سمير ديلو هم من ينفذون مباراه همم
الفوسفات وعمال الفوسفات هل هكذا ايضا
فهمت ان الرساله موجهه الى ولا فقط
[موسيقى]
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل همم السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه تجاهل المبادره السياسيه
لاتحاد الشغل قبل انقلاب 25 جويليا يوليو
2021 ثم هو يب
دي الكثافه الاتحاد وتشارك فيها جمعيات من
المنتظم المدني وهذا التحرش بالاتحاد كانت
اخر
هي همم تعيين عضو جديد
في الامام معروف
بخصومته الشديده مع القياده الحديديه
للاتحاد العام تونسي
يعني على ماذا يدل هذا التصريح الجديد ان
كان المعني به الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل همم لناحيه العلاقه بينه وبين
الرئيس وايضا انعكاس ذلك على المبادره
التي يقوم بها الاتحاد
الاتحاد يتحدث عن كلمه من المحرمات لدى
رئيس الجمهوريه وهي كلمه الحوار وكلمه
التشاركيه السيد الرئيس يؤمن بالانفراد
بالراي وهو قد دستورا على قياسه وقانونا
الانتخابيا كتبه بنفسه لنفسه وكانت نهايه
مساره هي الفشل الذريع من خلال ليست دخول
في التاريخ كما يقولون لكن دخول كتاب
جينيس للارقام القياسيه من حيث تدني نسبه
المشاركه اذا كل هذا الهروب الامام هو
مدفوع بمحرك وحيد هو الفشل
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد سمير ديلو المحامي
وعضو لجنه تنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه
وسيدنا الحسن اليحياوي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من تونس
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيبا ان بلاده
ستتسلم ما بين 120 الى 140 دبابه غربيه
حديثه اضاف كليب ستركز جميع الجهود
الدبلوماسيه لزياده الدعم العسكري لبلاده
كم ونوعا على حديثه
موبايل
كويس
لانه لا يزال يتعين على البعض اتخاذ
قرارات رسميه وفقا لاجراءاتهم الداخليه لا
يسعني الا ان اشير الى انه في الموجه
الاولى من الدعم ستتلقى القوات المسلحه
لاوكرانيا من 120 الى 140 دبابه غربيه
اوكرانيا تواصل العمل على توسيع التحالف
الدبابات وزياده المساعده نركز جميع
الجهود الدبلوماسيه لزياده الدعم العسكري
كما ونوعا
واذا طلبك هذا الحصول على مقاتلات اف 16
اختلفت الردود بين عواصم الغرب فقد قال
الرئيس الامريكي جون بيدن ان بلاده لن
تزود اكياس بهذه المقاتلات بينما قال رئيس
الوزراء البولندي
»
ان اي قرار بارسال طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا سيتم بتنسيق كاملا مع دول
النيترو اما الرئيس الفرنسي فلم يستبعد
القيامه باي شيء دعما باوكرانيا بما في
ذلك التزويد بالطائرات المقاتله لكن وفق
شروط معينه
هكذا
الاوكراني في مقاتلات اف 16 بدت واشنطن في
حمله الامداد بالدبابات رائده للحلف
الغربي فهل يحسم النفي الرئاسي الامريكي
التردد بين حلفاء كياب بشان المقاتلات
الامريكيه لماذا تريد اوكرانيا التزود
بمقاتلته اف 16 هي تعاني حاليا تراجعا في
مخزون صواريخ الدفاع الجوي ما ينذر بعجز
محتمل عن مواجهه المقاتلات والمسيرات
روسيه كما انها تستعد لما يعرف بهجوم
الربيع الذي تخطط له سعيا لاستعاده ما سقط
من اراضيها في يد الروس
التجاوب الامريكي ثم الغربي في الامداد
بالدبابات رفع مستوى توقعات الاوكرانيين
المترقبين لطائرات اف 16 لدرجه تجهيز
قائمه ل 50 طيارا
مستعدين للتدريب على المقاتله اف 16 لمده
ثلاثه اشهر تفوق السرعه قاتله اف 16 سرعه
الصوت وتبلغ 2000 و 400 كلم في الساعه
ولها القدره على الطيران في جميع الاحوال
الجويه والتزود بالوقود جوا كما يمكنها
حمل سته صواريخ جو جو ومدفع متعدد الفوهات
وذخائر جو جو ارض فضلنا عن القدره على
المناوره وضرب الاهداف على الارض والطيران
على ارتفاع المنخفض لتفادي الرادارات
الارضيه لذلك لن يكون التدريب على
استخدامها سريعا ولا سهلا بل قد يستغرق
الربيع المنتظر واكثر بالنظر ايضا لسابق
خبرات الطيارين الاوكرانيين البعيده عن
التقنيات الامريكيه وهي احد الاسباب
الفنيه للتحفظ الامريكيه بجانب متطلبات
بنيه تحتيه لتشغيل طائرات اف 16 قد لا
تكون متوفره في الساحه الاوكرانيه لكن
الدوافع السياسيه للموقف الامريكي اشد
اهميه فلا تخفي واشنطن منذ بدء الحرب
رفضها للتصعيد ضد بشكل يورطها هي في
مواجهه مباشره وهو ليس تحفظا امريكيا فقط
فحتى الرئيس الفرنسي الذي لم يغلق الباب
تماما امام تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله
اعتبر عدم الجنوح للتصعيد ضد روسيا شرطا
اساسيا بل ان رئيس الوزراء البولنديه الذي
قالت اوكرانيا انها تلقت منه اشارات
ايجابيه بشان تزويدها بمقاتلات اف 16 قال
ان الامر سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع النيتو وهو
اعتبار قد يواجه بعراق قيل امريكيه داخل
الحلف يعرف الروس فيما يبدو استغفر
العربيه لدعم اوكرانيا ولذلك علق الكريم
للنا على الموقف البولندي المتقدم وقال
الناطق باسمه بمتر ديسكو ان بولندا والدول
البلطيق مستعده لفعل كل ما يزيد المواجهه
مع روسيا دون نظر للعواقب
قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا ان البدء المبكر في المفاوضات
نحو عضويه اوكرانيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيكون الموضوع الرئيسي في القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه التي ستعقد يوم الجمعه المقبله
مضيفا ان بلاد تسعه الى احراز تقدم في
الاقتراب من السوق الاوروبيه الداخليه
والتعاونيه في قطاع الطاقه
رئيسه تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
مرحبا بك عقيده
الحسم من جانب الولايات المتحده بانه لن
يكون هناك تسليم لطائرات افسته عشر الى
اوكرانيا كيف سينعكس باعتقادك على مسار
القتال على الارض
حمله لم يكن لاين من الطرفين تفوقا في
الاشهر الاخيره وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
الوضع سيختلف بعد ذلك ولكن طبعا اوكرانيا
تخطط لعدد من العمليات وبالتالي هي ستحتاج
الى دعم جوي وتغطيه جويه لقواتها دخول هذا
السلاح في ما لو حصل
الى المعركه كيف من شان ان يبدل في موازين
القوى وايضا كيف من شانه ان ينعكس على
الازمه بين دول الغرب الداعمه لاوكرانيا
وروسيا
ايه كمان
فقط طلبه من محل شمال الاطلسي
عددا من التجهيزات الجويه منذ السنه
الاخيره وفي رساله وجهها حدد سبب الرئيسي
لطلب هذه الطائرات المقاتله قالوا لا ترسل
الينا سوخوي او مايك لاننا نعرف ان عروسه
تمتلك نفس انواع الطائره وبالتالي المزيد
من هذا طائر سوف لن تساعدنا في حل المشكله
ما تحتاج اليه اوكرانيا اليوم هو طائرات
اكثر تقدما من طائرات الروسيه وطائره
المقاتله الحديثه في روسيا هي بحاجه الى
طائرات مقاتله يمكنها ان تحلها
بالرغم من سلاح المضاد
في روسيا طيب همم بالنظر الى هذه الحاجه
التي تحدثت عنها هل يمكن ان نرى تغيرا
ربما في الموقف الامريكي في الاسابيع
المقبله على غرار ما حدث في موضوع
الدبابات
بالاضافه الى المدفعيه الطويله المدى كل
ما يتخطى 30 كلم يعتبر سلاحا فعالا
ودقيقا وبالنظر الى توفر هذا الانظمه
الاسيه مع الهايس
هي فعلا احداث تغيير في ميزان القوى والان
ومع وصول عدد من التجهيزات الخاصه
بالموشات وعدد من
الدبابات فهي ايضا سوف تحدث فرقا اذا قررت
اوكرانيا ان تستانف عملياتها
رئيس وتحرير المجله العسكريه سويسريه
ضيفنا من جنيف
[موسيقى]
من طوكيو دعى الامين العام لحلفي شمال
الاطلسي ايام
تعزيز التعاون بين النت واليابان لمواجهه
التحديات العالميه وكان صوت البرج قد
استهل جولته في منطقه شرق اسيا بزياره
لكوريا الجنوبيه التي زارها ايضا وزير
الدفاع الامريكي
الى الاتفاق على تدريبات ثلاثيه الاطراف
تشمل الولايات المتحده واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
لا ضيره في زياره الحلفاء قد يستسهل قولها
غير عارف بسياق هذا الحراك الغربي في
منطقه شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادي الى
المنطقه المتوتره امنيا في الاساس يحمل
وزير الدفاع الامريكي رساله دعم ثابت
لكوريا الجنوبيه وبقيه الشركاء
لا يقف الامر كما يبدو عند القرار المتخذ
بتوسيع مستوى تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
ونطاقها فتمت تحالفات ستتعزز بل قد تتخذ
اشكالا جديده مختلفه
ليس سرا ان الامريكيين يروغون كبحا نفود
الصيني المتصاعد الطامح في رايهم للهيمنه
وليس اقل عزما على مواجهه ما يرونه
تهديدات متزايده من كوريا الشماليه
للاستقرار العالمي لم تتبدل اذن
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الامريكيه وحده
المعطى النووي دخل على الخط ليعزز اجراءات
الرضع التقليديه لحمايه الحلفاء
عن جمهوريه السابق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ملتزمه
بالردع وهذا يشمل القدرات الامريكيه
الكامله بما في ذلك القدرات الدفاعيه
التقليديه والنوويه والصاروخيه
في شمال الاطلسي في طريقه كما يبدو لبناء
ما يشبه حلفا نيته بصيغه اسيويه
في ظل العقيده الدفاعيه اليابانيه الجديده
مع اليابان لمواجهه ما يقول انها التحديات
العالميه التي تشكلها الحرب الروسيه
الاخرانيه
في شمال الاطلسي بان الامن هنا حيث التوتر
وهناك الحرب مترابط بشكل وثيق لكنه بيان
ايضا لخريطه المحاور التي تضع روسيا
والصين وكوريا الشماليه في مواجهه الغرب
وحلفائه الاسيويين يذهب الامير العام لحلف
الناتو ابعد حين يقول ان حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وتعاونها العسكريه المتنامي مع
الصين او جزاء ما وصفها باخطر بيئه امنيه
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه كلمات كفيله
باستفزاز بيجينج وهم يراقبون بقلق
التحركات الغربيه في محيطهم يؤكد الصينيون
بان تلك التحركات عينها هي ما قد يجلب نظر
الحرب الى المنطقه
بعد قليل وفي فقره المتابعه نستمع الى
وجهتي نظر من بيجين واشنطن بشان طبيعيه
لمن يعنيه الامر
[موسيقى]
نظمت كبريته نقابه الفرنسيه واحزاب اليسار
مظاهرات واضطرابات واسعه في البلاد
احتجاجا على اعتزامي الحكومه اجراء
تعديلات على قانون التقاعد ستؤدي الى رفع
السن القانونيه الى 64 عاما
قناه لدى النقابات الفرنسيه مفادها ان
اسقاط مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يتطلب
تعبئه استثنائيه
راموس اقناع المواطنين بضروره الانضمام
الى الحركه الاحتجاجيه
64 عاما هو متوسط العمر الذي يكون خلاله
الانسان في صحه جيده لكن الحكومه تريد ان
نعمل الى ان نبلغ هذه السن الهدف هو
استغلال العمال واهمالهم بعد ذلك وتركهم
يعيشون بمعاشات بائسه قبل الذهاب الى
القبر
امتعاد نخففت من حذته المشاركه الواسعه في
هذه الاحتجاجات غضب عارم قد لا يلوي ذراع
الحكومه الفرنسيه حسب نتالي لكنه سيقوي من
عزيمه الرافدين لهذا المشروع على حد
تعبيرها
اذا اثرت الحكومه على موقفها فستمر
محاولتنا لاسقاط مشروع اصلاح قانون
التقاعد
بس ذلك اصرار لم يغيب عن تصريحات هؤلاء
الذين فاقى عددهم في مسيره باريس وحدها
5000 حسب تقديرات النقابات محتجون من
شرائح عمريه مختلفه يرفضون حجج الحكومه
التي تذهب الى انه لا بديل عن رفع سن
التقاعد الى 40 سنه
جهاز على ابسط حقوق العمال واستهداف
المباشر لمن افنوا حياتهم في بناء هذا
الوطن يرد هؤلاء مواكدين ان هذه المعركه
الحقوقيه ليست الاخيره
ان العمال هم من يشغلون هذا البلد اليوم
اوقفنا القطارات وحركه المواصلات وغدا لن
يخرج الوقود من محطات التكريم هل الحكومه
ان تعيانا كل هذا سيوقف العمل في البلاد
اسرار الحكومه الفرنسيه على تمرير مشروعيه
اصلاح نظام التقاعد يقابله تصميم النقابات
على اسقاطه وفي انتظار الحزم تقول
النقابات ان هذه ليست سوى نذر يسيرا من
الاحتجاجات التي تعتزم خوضها ايمن الزبير
الجزيره الجزيره باريس
[موسيقى]
زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي
وهي الثالثه له منذ تواليه منصبه كيف يبدو
المشهد في هذه المنطقه تصعدت التوترات
والعسكريه في شبه الجزيره الكوريه بحدا في
2000 واثنين 2020 مع اجراء كوريا الشماليه
عددا قياسيا من تجارب الاسلحه ومن ضمنها
اطلاق صاروخ باليستيا عابر للقارات هو
الاكثر تطورا وفي اول حادثه من نوعها خلال
50 سنوات عبرت خمس سيارات كوريه شماليه
الحدود في ديسمبر الماضي ورده كوريا
الجنوبيه بتحريك طائرات الحربيه على
الحدود بدايه العام الحالي دعا الزعيم
الكوري الشمالي الى زياده هائله في ترسله
بلاده النوويه مما فيها الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه وتطويري صواريخ جديده ردا على
وصفه بالعداء الامريكي والكوري الجنوب وقد
دفع ذلك الرئيسه الكوريه الجنوبي
يونسوكيول الى طرح فكره حيازه بلاده اسلحه
نوويه قبل ان يتراجع عن ذلك لاحقا مؤكدا
تاييد السول لمنع الانتشار النووي العالمي
ويعني ذلك استمرار كوريا الجنوبيه في
الاعتماد على التزام الولايات المتحده
بحمايتها ضد اي تهديد من جارتها النوويه
اذا هو تعزيز للتحالف الاستراتيجي بين سول
و واشنطن الممتد منذ 70 عاما ومن ابرز اسس
ذلك التحالف ودعائمه تاكيد واشنطن
الالتزامها بحمايه حليفتها كوريا الجنوبيه
بما في ذلك استخدام الرضع النووي في وجه
تهديدات
بدءا من فبراير هذا العام سيوسع البلدان
مستوى التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه كما
ونوعا وفق سيناريوهات تحاكي التعامل مع
هجوم نووي وفي اكتوبر الماضي اجرى البلدان
اكبر مناورات جويه مشتركه نفذت خلالها نحو
مئتين 240 طائره بل نفذت نحو 240 طائره
حربيه الاف الطلاعات والغارات على اهداف
افتراضيه كما ترتبط كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده واليابان باتفاق يسمح
لدول الثلاث بتبادل فوريا ومباشرا لبيانات
التحديث من الصواريخ المعاديه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيجين الدكتور
فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس مركزي الصين
والعولمه ومعنى من واشنطن الدكتور ريتشارد
وايدز رئيس قسم دراسات الصين بمعهد حسن
مرحبا بكما سيد فيكتوريا معك باي عين
تراقب الصين هذه التحركات
والتصريحات ل همم امين عام حلف الناتو في
كل من كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان وايضا الان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ماتش
الاستضافه الان هو ان ال في اليابان وفي
كوريا الجنوبيه مقلقه للغايه لانها قد
تؤثر في الزعزعه امني واستقرار المنطقه
ماذا يمكن نسال اولا
يعني يفعل الامين العام لحلف النيته في
كوريا الجنوبيه وفي اليابان هو
منظمته تعنى بشمال الاطلسي لماذا هذه
المنطقه التي هي بعيده عنه جغرافيا
وسياسيا وماذا يفعله ياتي هذه المنطقه
التي اسيا قال انه يريد زياده التعاون بين
الحلف من جهه وكل من كوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان من جهه ثانيه
التحديات التي فرضتها الحرب حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا والتعاون بين روسيا والصين
لماذا ينبغي ان يقلق احد حول روسيا والصين
هذان بلدان جاراني يتقاسماني حدود طويله
تتجاوز
4300 كيلو متر
وهذه الحدود
في حاله من السلام والاستقرام ومنظر عام
89 وخاصه بمنظر العامه
1991 عندما ظهرت روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي هل هم يريدون زعزعه الحدود
الروسيه الصينيه هذه يريدون تحويل
الاستقرار في حدودتين الى حاله من عدم
الاستقرار والكراهيه والتحرير اذا ما اراد
اي طرف ان يساهم في تعزيز السلام
الروسيه في حاله من الوئام ذاق والسلام
هذا هو وهذه النقاط الدكتور ريتشارد وايتس
دكتور ريتشارد هذه التصريحات التي تؤشر
الى ما تنوي القيام به كل من الولايات
المتحده وهمم حلف الناتو من زياده التعاون
العسكري بين كل بينهما مع اليابان من جهه
وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه اخرى الم يساهم في
اذكاء المشاكل والتوترات في تلك المنطقه
قضيه ان السبب والتاثير على عكس ما هو
متصور
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
من حيث
الشماليه وهما ايضا قلقت ثاني حول مهاجمه
روسيه اللي اوكرانيا واوربما يخشون من ان
تفعل او تحضيره
ليس هو سبب زياده التوتر هل هو نتيجه
للتوتر وتابع لها
وبالتالي زياده العسكر في المنطقه مما قد
يؤدي الى المزيد من التوتر لماذا لا يتم
العمل على همم حل هذه الامور بشكل لا يؤدي
الى المزيد من التوتر
بيتنا
لا يرون هذان
الخيارين كشيء قائم بشكل
ذاته
ما يتعلق بتعزيز التعاون بين حرس
النيترونات المتحده واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
من ان تقوم بالمزيد من
الاعتداءات وايضا ستثنى الصين وكوريا
الشماليه من ان تحضروا حظو روسيا في
اوكرانيا اذا هذه دبلوماسيه على اساسا
يجمع بين العمل الدبلوماسيه والتعاون
العسكريه الدفاعيه في اذاعه
المشكله اصلا اوجدتها همم التصرفات من
جانب كوريا الشماليه التهديد بالصواريخ
البالستيه لكوريا الجنوبيه ايضا اليابان
وكذلك التصريحات تصريحات الرئيس الكوري
الشمالي حول الموضوع النووي
اذا كان هناك
تصور لديك بالعمى الجزئي والانحياز ستتوقف
عند هذا الحظ لكن ينبغي ان تسال سؤال اخر
لماذا تريد الكره الشماليه ان تصلح نفسها
بالصواريخ نوويه هل ستؤكل هذه الصواريخ
بالطبع لا لكن هم يريدون اثبات ان لديهم
القدرات
لامتلاكها واطلاقها من قبل الامام انظروا
الى التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه التي
تقوم بها المتحده والتي تدخل فيها اسلحه
نوويه وقاذفات استراتي مواجهه ضد ثمان
موجود
الشماليه وهي واحده البلدان
ردك على هذه الجزئيه
نور
الشماليه اذا ما كانت فقط تسعى لهذه
الامتلاك هذه الاسلحه لاغراض دفاعيه سيكون
هذا مقلقا لكن يمكن احتوائه لكن الخوف
الذي يساوي الناس
يمكن ان استخدم السلاح النبوي كادر
نائب رئيس مركز الصين شكرا لكم
ثلاث سنوات مرت منذ اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه لاول مره ان فيروس كورونا يشكل
حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه توفي نحو سبعه
ملايين شخص عبر انحاء العالمي بالوفاء
واصيب عشرات الملايين وانهكت الاقتصادات
والمجتمعات ورغم هول تلك الجائحه وتفوقها
على اي زلزال او جفافا او اعصار في
التاريخ فان العالم لا يبدو مستعدا اليوم
كما يلزم لمواجهه او بيئه المستقبل ذلك ما
حذر منه تقرير الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر مرجحا ان
تكون الجائحه القادمه قريبه للغايه
والتساؤل هو اذا لم تحفزنا تجربه 19 لتاهب
فما الذي سيحفزنا على ذلك سؤال المشروع
يدعو الاطراف المعنيه الى وضع الخطط
والاستعداد لاي تفشل محتمل للجوائح ويبقى
الامل الامل يدرك الجميع خطوره الموقف
ونتعلم من محنه كورونا المؤلمه دمتم بالف
خير شكرا لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]